hallo mein name ist supernett winter
kommen heute zu einem neuen video
contest im internet gewonnen und waren
nur vier von 50 erwachsene ändern sich
an diesem kindheit duell ja das gucken
[Applaus]
warst du ein musterschüler oder er ein
rebell sinnfragen 46 von 50 erwachsenen
versagen schafft für den test wie kriegt
noch einmal direkt auf losgeht sind
delfine fische oder säugetiere
wenn sie fische wären dann würden sie
eier legen und leute tiere da kommt ihr
witz weiter ich glaube delfine sind
säugetiere das heiße man mit der
nächsten frage kann staub aus afrika bis
nach florida schweben wenn er so blöd
fragt eigentlich schon oder klickt man
einfach auf ja mein name ist diese frage
zu viel prozent die frage seiner
komplett war ist schon die 4 prozent
besteht ein gehirn aus wasser ich glaube
das sind 75 prozent also unser körper
besteht der allgemeinen traut enorm viel
wasser bewegen
75% kriege ich einfach mal an nächste
frage gibt es im wörterbuch etwas
natürlich auch orange rein und ich
glaube nicht an wunder gesagt mir leute
überhaupt
ich würde einfach mal sagen nein das
heißt die lange lebt ein hund
durchschnittlich energien und ich habe
keine und hab keine ahnung so war vor
allem weiß man nicht ob das jetzt hunde
oder menschen jahre bis 1990 bis 24 25
19 14
denn ich würde sagen 15 bis 19 irgendwie
so um den dreh wie viele sinne hat der
mensch hören fühlen schmecken
hauptnachricht 4 3 oder 4 auf die haut
eine tiger ist gestreift genau wie sein
zelt ich nebenbei irgendwas google oder
so deswegen ich sage einfach mal stimmt
wir wollen ja wirklich schauen uns du
bist wirklich 246 von 50 mg hinkriegen
dein herz ist in etwa so gross wieder
ein fuß dein ohr ein fingernagel dein
gehirn deinen ihre deine faust ich würde
sagen kläger so groß wie die faust wie
viele steine wurden im empire state
building fahrzeug überhaupt steine nicht
egal aluminium und so relativ viele
leute im dorf und 10.000 zehn millionen
hunderttausender 100 millionen kommen
leute okay ich würde einfach mal sagen
zehn millionen oder so das ist ein ganz
guter mittelwert gibt es mehr sterne im
universum oder sandkörner auf der erde
[Musik]
wow das ist richtig kranke frage ich hab
gedacht ok es gibt auf der erde halt so
enorm viel dann ich mein allein der
ganze boden auch wenn es ihm wie merck
oder so sehr alle zusammen und wenn man
sich überlegt dass man kleine hornist du
alleine hand wollen zehn millionen oder
so aber sterne im universum ich mein das
universum ist ja auch in die unendlich
großes heißt es gibt locker eigentlich
mehr stören ich war aber immer
sandkörner einfach irgendwie sterne
banana und das war ich mal richtig ene
mene miste es rappelt in der kiste ene
mene meck und luca ita gewarnt meine
damen und herren nächste frage wie lange
lebt ein löwe im durchschnitt dicker
das sind so fragen die die jungen
einfach keinen entweder zwölf jahre
sechs jahre 39 jahre oder 27 jahre
ich glaube ich da einfach mal 27 jahre
wieder ganz guter wert schweine können
keinen sonnenbrand bekommen dass das
habe ich sogar mal irgendwo gehört gibt
es wörter die sich auch wilde einen
klang ja oder silber city so krank was
ist richtig rubinette haben mehr haare
als blondinen blondinen haben mehr haare
als brünette vom wetter haben mehr haare
was ist das größte auf dem land lebende
säugetiere welt eine giraffe ein
nilpferd ein grauer oder eine
elefantenkuh sorry leute das muss ich
ganz gut meistern überhaupt nicht weiß
was ist ein paar sekunden später sehr
interessant ist ihr also in jedem fall
nicht ich würde einfach mal sagen ihr
affe ist ja schon relativ groß und jetzt
wie viele wiener haben heidinger ich bin
mir nicht sicher ob ich die antwort mit
den sinnen einen menschen richtig
beantwortet haben jetzt kommt die seite
mitteilen ich sage einfach trotzdem 4
und dann haben wir nämlich jetzt als
letzter
frage wer hat mehr knochen babys oder
erwachsene ich glaube sogar babys oder
war das ist okay leute hier stellen wir
warten jetzt einfach mal ab wie viele
antworten kommt eine aufwertung wie viel
ich richtig habe ich habe keine ahnung
was das hier jetzt irgendwie soll also
entschied aber auch in der titel schon
notiert von 50 erwachsene erinnern sich
an ihre kindheit setzt also ja ich
gehöre leider zu den leuten wird nicht
daran erinnern leute bevor das video
jetzt hier endet habe ich noch eine ganz
kurze sache bezüglich eines treffens in
wien in zwei wochen an 22 orten dass es
morgen in zwei wochen wenn ich nämlich
in wien beide fehlen die worte von der
veranstaltung von einem youtube netzwerk
studio 71 unter anderem ich mag wird
auch da seien viele andere youtuber
werden auch noch am stand während mama
zwei autogramme geben ihr könnt euch uns
mit uns unterhalten treffen fotos machen
die das anna kommt jetzt aber zum
wichtigsten sache und zwar wenn ihr
daran teilnehmen möchtet müsst ihr
natürlich ticket kaufen also kommt
natürlich nicht rein deswegen habe ich
ganz oben in die beschreibung hier unter
dem video den link reingehauen wohl
richtig gebrauchen können sie kosten
eigentlich 20 euro es gibt da waren
gutscheincode hashtags hier geht sie
unterstrich luca in denen dort ein geht
bekommt quasi von prora partners die
zahl 15 euro es aber mehr oder weniger
profil hat ein treffen weil in für die
15 euro die dann bezahlt bekommen ihr
wenn ihr da hingeht sollen beute mit so
geschenken und allen möglichen und die
beute alleine fand ich euro wert also
letztendlich scott free das treffen
ich möchte mich auf jeden fall sehr
freuen wenn wir uns sehen können der
gutscheincode ist auch 500 limitiert und
ich da auch noch ein ticket verkauft und
schnell wenn wir dahin kommen wollte und
will ich sage jetzt hab ich mich überall
eifrig sind dort oben jetzt eine smiley
eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf könnten die
kosten jetzt keine videos werden sind
auch menschen eingeblendet war am ersten
wechseln oder anderen diese cajun wird
und hier unten ist
video kauf der tickets dann sehen wir
uns